as your porn and sex addiction affected
your studies work marriage and family
relationship are you stuck with feelings
of guilt shame remorse and despair or
has your addiction progressed from
pornography to zina well we're here to
tell you you're not alone itasca is the
place where muslim males and females
struggling with pornography addictions
can find recovery and freedom
assalamu alaikum welcome to a better
career brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are worried
inshallah before i start one of the
praise i also plan on talking the most
most of the most just or praise his
glory and gratitude belong to him this
video video this very video that we're
going to be watching brother sisters
we're going to get some one key point
which is so important for all of us and
it shows us the consequences of what
happens
when one of us slip up let's watch the
video and see what exactly happened this
is a video of a australian police
officer a very nice police officer a
gentleman who stops over a hijabi and
breathalyzes her this is what she had to
say let's see for ourselves
don't worry officer we're muslim
it's haram to drink
please
and i know that's what they say can you
believe some of the biggest readings
i've ever had of people that have come
out of
saudi arabia and places like that that
are over here as international students
really they have a few and i think wow
this is just fantastic this stuff well
very very important lesson now the
sister is obviously a bit surprised you
know this assistant she's she's not the
one that was she wasn't drinking she's
surprised because she's like come on
officer you know i'm a muslim
the officer said something so profound
that might be true we can't generalize
everyone
but
if he has come across someone who wore
the hijab or the nikaba whatever it may
be
and was drinking
he cannot dismiss that now he cannot
come and say she's a hijabi or he wears
a cross or he's a jew or whatever it may
be
one instance one instance of seeing a
jewish person do something wrong or a
christian person or a hindu or a sikh or
a muslim whoever it may be
automatically what it does is it tells
the individual that
there's a possibility that they may also
be doing it so now
he will look at every hijabi who's
driving
with a question mark of they might be
drunk
do you see guys how once the pop can
have a ripple effect that is the reason
why we need to understand the
responsibility nobody's asking anyone to
be perfect we knew whether hijab but
this goes for brothers as well with
beard and a phobe or a topi whatever it
may be but you see that when we rest up
in an islamic attire we carry a big
responsibility because if i i'm being
robbed if i see a police officer i'm
going to run if i see someone dressed as
a police officer i'm gonna run to them
because that's what their religion
symbolizes i expect them to protect me
he's not gonna turn around to me and say
oh just cause i'm dressed up as a police
officer you uh doesn't mean i'm a police
officer there is certain expectations
people are entitled to believe but that
is the reason why for example with the
hijab in the camp it's lost his absolute
respect so much so that sisters who wear
the hijab or the niqab walking down the
street get catcalled why because these
men have come across girls who
indulge in certain things and they have
realized and said you know what the
symbol has lost this respect sadly now
this doesn't mean we still do not wear
the hijab or grow the beard or whatever
it may be but what that means is we need
to put extra effort in and what that
shows us and all of us should learn is
that one mistake that you make comes at
the cost of all of us being labeled just
as people common commit atrocities in
the name of islam we are the ones that
end up suffering it's sad it's sad you
know subhanallah that sisters or
brothers in hijab or whatever they're
wearing are drink driving which is a
danger to people's lives you can kill
them you're drink driving and on top of
that you're wearing a hijab or having a
beard or whatever it may be subhanallah
may allah forgive us uh for making them
making his religion look bad committing
a major sin
with the attire that we should be
representing
brothers and sisters until next time
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi